[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Serien einen schönen guten
Abend ihnen allen gute Nachrichten gibt
es später ausführlich am Sportring
schöne Erfolgsgeschichten guten Abend
hier sind unsere Themen an diesem
Samstag
Auftritt der Weltmächte auf der
Sicherheitskonferenz kündigt China eine
Friedensinitiative im Ukraine Krieg an
aber die USA sind misstrauisch
Notstand in Nordsyrien nach dem Erdbeben
kommt die Hilfe in den rebellengebieten
an der türkischen Grenze nur schleppend
voran
und WM-Medaillen im Wintersport die
deutschen Biathletinnen holen Staffel
Silber und Lena Dürr jubelt im Slalom
über Bronze
[Musik]
spannender Tag 2 bei der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz zwischen den USA
und China gab es diplomatische
Scharmützel auf offener Bühne
gleichzeitig plant Peking kurz vor dem
Jahrestag zum Kriegsbeginn offenbar eine
Friedensinitiative nach langer
chinesischer Zurückhaltung im Konflikt
durchaus auffällig Thomas Reichert
wie es Frieden in der Ukraine geben
könnte dazu haben die Mächtigen in
München ganz unterschiedliche
Vorstellungen Chinas oberster
Außenpolitiker wangi kündigt heute eine
Initiative zur beiligung des Krieges an
worin sie genau besteht sagt wann nicht
dafür aber worauf China besteht
für eine sichere Welt ist die
Souveränität und territoriale Integrität
aller Länder etwas das geachtet werden
muss macht Politik und Hegemonie sind
ein Rezept für globale Instabilität und
dies verursacht den größten Schaden am
weltweiten Frieden
es könnte eine Friedensbotschaft sein
für die Ukraine und gegen Russland bei
Wangen ist es eher eine Drohung
gegenüber Taiwan das Peking als Teil
Chinas betrachtet die US Vizepräsidentin
wiederum droht Peking Putins Krieg mit
mehr als Propaganda zu unterstützen das
wäre eine rote Linie
jeder Schritt Chinas Russland mit
tödlichen Waffen zu unterstützen würde
die Aggression nur belohnen das Töten
fortsetzen und die auf Regeln beruhende
internationale Ordnung untergraben
selbst unterstellt den USA die
Mentalität des Kalten Krieges sei wieder
da
möglicherweise gibt es einige Kräfte den
sind Friedensgespräche nicht recht gegen
ist das Leben der Ukraine
wann liefert kein Beleg für sein Vorwurf
aus der Satz in der Zeit ist dass die
Suche nach Frieden in der Ukraine Teil
eines großen Ringens geworden ist
zwischen China und den USA
sprechen wir noch mal über den Plan
einer chinesischen Friedensinitiative
mit Katrin Eugendorf in Haake und ultra
in München Ulf du warst ja auch lange
unser Korrespondentin was steckt denn
hinter dieser chinesischen Ankündigung
als ich fand das schon ein ziemlich
interessanten Schachzug der chinesischen
Diplomatie ich glaube es geht ihnen
darum sich als moralische Weltmacht zu
präsentieren man hat halt eben das Wort
friedenitiative in den Mund genommen das
weckt sehr viel Fantasie ohne konkret zu
sagen was es gibt und man will damit
auch das Bild zeigen china ist für
Frieden und der Westen diskutiert hier
auf der Konferenz über knopfpanzer und
Kampfjets und man will den besten damit
herausfordern will wirklich gucken wie
groß ist die Solidarität des Westens mit
der Ukraine oder gibt es doch
kriegsmütigkeit war vor allem in der
Gesellschaft der westlichen Länder die
Antwort der Amerikaner war sehr sehr
deutlich wir haben gerade die Warnung
der Vizepräsidentin gesehen und daran
sieht man was eigentlich die Botschaft
von der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
ist die ein bisschen traurig ist denn
man hat wirklich den Eindruck dass der
Kalte Krieg hier auch eine Rolle
gespielt hat und dass die beiden
Weltmeister sich doch sehr feindlich
gegenüberstehen
weiter nach hakif zu dir Kathrin wie
realistisch ist es denn aktuell aus
ukrainische Perspektive einen
Friedensplan in Gang zu bringen
also erstmals aus ukrainischer
Perspektive China kein glaubwürdiger
Verhandlungspartner aber was hier hat
durch doch aufhorchen lassen ist das
Wort territoriale Integrität das China
sagt dass das wichtig wäre und zu
erzielen wäre das ist ja das worum es
den Ukraine geht aber die ukrainische
Regierung und auch Präsident selenski
hat ja wiederholt klar gemacht was ganz
klar die Bedingung ist um überhaupt hier
in Verhandlungen gehen zu können das ist
dass sich die russische Armee komplett
aus ukrainischem und von ukrainischen
Staatsgebiet zurückzieht und ihre
Kämpfer einstellt das heißt das im
Prinzip die Grenzen von 1991 zu achten
sind also auch dass sich russischen
russisches Militär aus dem Osten der
Ukraine und auch von der Krim
zurückziehen muss diese Situation das
Russland dazu bereit wäre daraus dafür
gibt es im Moment aus ähm ukrainischer
Perspektive überhaupt gar keine
Anzeichen vielen Dank Katrin Nachhilfe
und auch nach München
Hintergründe und Analysen zu einem Jahr
Ukraine Krieg wie diese ZDF heute-story
über die Folgen für Russlands handeln
mit der Welt finden Sie bei uns online
und in der ZDF heute App
ein Jahr Krieg in der Ukraine ein Jahr
in dem sich das Leben der
Zivilbevölkerung dramatisch verändert
hat die Gefahr russische Angriffe gehört
jeden Tag zum Leben im Krieg dazu
befragte ein französisches Kamerateam
ukrainische Reisende auf einer Zugfahrt
von West nach Ost eine Momentaufnahme
und Christian Volk fast diese Bilder
zusammen
jedes Mal wenn von Lemberg ein Zug quer
durchs Land ins östliche haarkiff
startet dann fahren hunderte Geschichten
mit alle ein die Angst plötzlich zur
Zielscheibe zu werden
falls es zu einer Explosion kommt
erklärt Nicola haben wir Klebeband gegen
die Glasscherben angebracht
in Wagen 8 sitzt Alexander zu Beginn des
Krieges war er nach Deutschland geflohen
seine frühere Wohnung bei Kiew
bombardiert ausgebrannt nur noch ein
Foto auf dem Handy und dennoch will er
zurück in die Heimat
an ich muss eine neue Wohnung und eine
neue Arbeit finden ich kann doch nicht
ewig Flüchtling bleiben
ein Waggon weiter ähnliches Alter völlig
andere Gründe für die Zugfahrt diese
drei sind gerade in die Armee eingezogen
worden fahren als Mediziner an die Front
von dort kommt Igor er hat den bachmut
gekämpft von seiner Einheit mit 100
Soldaten hätten nur acht überlebt
erzählt er
die Ukraine in den Schützengräben sind
nicht unsterblich sie werden sterben
deshalb braucht es andere um sie zu
ersetzen Männer die sich noch nicht
gemeldet haben müssen das jetzt tun
der Krieg wird erst einmal ohne Igor
weitergehen er erholt sich nun bei
seiner Frau und seiner Familie
12 Tage nach dem Erdbeben in der Türkei
und Syrien steigt die Zahl der Toten
weiter mehr als 46.000 sind es
mittlerweile laut Behörden und viele
Menschen werden noch vermisst frisches
Wasser und Sanitäranlagen fehlen die
solchen Gefahr steigt Bundeskanzler
Scholz kündigte weitere Hilfe aus
Deutschland an an vielen Orten herrscht
zwischen den Trümmern große Verzweiflung
berichtet aus Syrien
eine Stadt die Zufluchtsort war für
zehntausende Syrer aus allen Ecken des
Landes jetzt eine Geisterstadt nur noch
sehr weniger Häuser sind bewohnbar
abdulilla Jumper blickt auf seine
Wohnung seine Frau hat er verloren als
die Decke über ihnen einstürzte seine
Kinder liegen in Krankenhäusern die
Tochter mit Frakturen am Hals und Nacken
dem Sohn musste er gerade Blut spenden
niemand kümmere sich um ihn sagte
selbst wenn die Vereinten Nationen hier
ankämen und uns jetzt Zelte geben wir
hätten sie im Moment nach dem Beben
gebraucht um zu retten zu bergen was
hier passiert ist beweist dass wir von
unseren eigenen Behörden hier von den UN
von allen Ländern ignoriert werden von
allen
ein un-inspektionsteam ist zum ersten
Mal physisch vor Ort und gerade
ingenieures angekommen sie schauen was
gebraucht wird sie wollen sprechen mit
den zersplitterten Gruppen die Nordwest
Syrien beherrschen alle Kritik an ihrer
zu späten Reaktion nach dem Beben alle
Vorwürfe nicht entschlossen genug
gehandelt zu haben weisen sie zurück
unser Nothilfe Koordinator hat sich
entschuldigt seit dem korrigieren wir
unseren Kurs
wir wollen zum Beispiel dass wir den
Menschen hier vielleicht bessere
würdigere Unterkünfte geben nicht nur
Zelte oder dass die Kinder wieder zur
Schule gehen können
davon sind sie weit entfernt das einzige
das hier wächst sagen die Erdbeben Opfer
bitter seien Syrer in Zelten von denen
gab es schon vor dem Leben
hunderttausende
es ist sehr kalt wir schlafen auf dem
Boden es gibt nichts zum heizen wir
können nicht schlafen wir haben nicht
mal Brennmaterial zum verbrennen
Nordwest Syrien jetzt eine Krise in der
Krise und eine Erinnerung daran dass die
Welt Syrien nicht einfach übersehen kann
solchen verhindern weisen Schwangere und
viele andere im Katastrophengebiet
unterstützen das ist möglich über das
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe die
IBAN lautet
de65-100 400 600-100 400 600 Stichwort
ZDF Erdbeben Türkei Syrien nachzulesen
auch auf
spenden.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf der
Seite 89.0
ein Brief mit Morddrohung und
revolverpatrone sorgt in Berlin
parteiübergreifend für Empörung
adressiert war er an die Grünen
Spitzenkandidatin Bettina jarasch die
regierende spd-bürgermeisterin Franziska
Giffey reagiert entsetzt jemanden wegen
politischer Überzeugung mit Hass und
Drogen zu überziehen überschreite jede
Grenze jetzt ermittelt der Staatsschutz
gut zwei Wochen ist es her der
entgleiste im US-Bundesstaat Ohio ein
mit Chemikalien beladener Zug in
etlichen der fast 50 entleisten Waggons
waren leicht entzündliche Stoffe
gelagert insbesondere das krebserregende
Vinylchlorid die Behörden entschieden
sich für ein kontrolliertes Abfackeln
kurz danach stieg ein gigantischer
schwarzer Rauchpilz in den Himmel und
seitdem Unglück bangen die Anwohner in
East Palace sein um ihre Gesundheit
Benjamin Daniel
ein Politiker filmt wie er mit einem
Stock Wasser in einem Bach aufwühlt die
Verseuchung ist mit bloßem Auge sichtbar
rund um die Uhr arbeiten unter anderem
die lokalen Behörden und Helfer daran
den Unglücksort so gut wie möglich von
den freigesetzten Chemikalien zu säubern
weitere Unterstützung kommt nun aus
Washington
der Gouverneur hat zusätzliche Hilfe
angefragt mehr Gesundheitstest und
Expertise wir schicken nun Teams des
gesundheitspflegeministeriums und der
Gesundheitsbehörde
während Regierung und Behörden versuchen
zu beruhigen steigt der frustrationsgrad
bei Anwohnern auch wenn es offiziell
heißt Luft und Trinkwasser sein
ungefährlich haben die Menschen vor Ort
Angst
sind meine Kinder sicher ist der Rest
unserer Gemeinde sicher
ich kann die Gase in meinem Haus riechen
auch die Ursachenforschung läuft auf
Hochtouren dieses Überwachungsvideo
zeigt Funken an den Zug Rädern schon
rund eine Dreiviertelstunde vor der
Entgleisung warum der Zug nicht gestoppt
wurde ist weiter unklar der Gouverneur
fordert nun vom US-Kongress sich
grundlegend mit der Sicherheit des
güterzugverkehrs auseinanderzusetzen
sie müssen prüfen welche Substanzen man
per Zug transportieren kann welche
Verantwortung das zugunternehmen hat und
ob man nicht eine pflichteinführen
sollte das Starten im Vorfeld über
solche risikotransporte informiert
werden sollten die
örtlichen Behörden fürchten nun das
Regen noch mehr Schadstoffe in Bäche und
Flüsse spülen könnte und so werden die
Reinigungsarbeiten vor Ort weiter
andauern genauso wie die Suche nach der
Antwort auf die Frage wie das alles
passieren konnte
wir blicken jetzt wieder zur Berlinale
und einer Romanverfilmung die dort
Weltpremiere feiert der Comedian felix
lobrecht hat vor einigen Jahren
aufgeschrieben wie es war in der
Neuköllner Hochhaussiedlung Gropiusstadt
aufzuwachsen Sonne und Beton hieß das
Debüt wurde gefeiert und erzählt von
Freundschaften und dem Überleben in
einem teils brutalen Umfeld und daraus
ist jetzt eben ein Film geworden Nadia
nasser
Neukölln goes Berlinale großer Auftritt
für das Filmteam von Sonne und Beton
nach Felix lobrechts Geschichte über
Jugendliche im Problemkiez
Gropiusstadt Sommer 2003 es ist die
Heimat von Lukas und seinen Freunden
Stopp
eine harte Welt voller Gewalt auf der
Straße
und Konflikten zu Hause
spannend irgendwie aus dem Leben von den
Leuten zu erzählen die da einfach so
ganz normal wohnen die ist irgendwie
schwer haben die keine Kohle haben die
aus schwierigen Familienverhältnissen
kommen auch in der Schule regiert das
Chaos der aufgestaute Frust bricht sich
ungehindert Bahn
okay dann hol dir jetzt zu dritt Kreide
hey
was mit den Computer noch zur Schule wir
brechen in die Schule ein und Klauen die
Dinger das wird so einfach
ein ungeschönter Blick auf das
Aufwachsen in den Hochhausschluchten der
Großstadt
es spiegelt eigentlich ganz gut wieder
wie ein Leben von
Jugendlichen in einem Brennpunkt sein
kann weshalb ich auch finde dass der
Film so eine
Echtheit ausstrahlt ja er zeigt einfach
so viele Sachen unzensiert so sehr raus
sehr klar
wenigstens Sommer Sonne und Beton ja
Neukölln im Scheinwerferlicht der
Berlinale heute Abend ist weltpremiere
jetzt zum Sport und viel Freude über WM
Medaillen und ein paar Tränen gab es
auch Christian alles Glücksgefühle
Vorletzter Tag beim Biathlon in Oberhof
dritte Medaille für Denise Herrmann Wick
die als Schlussläuferin bei schwierigen
Bedingungen am Rennsteig mit ihren drei
Staffel Kolleginnen WM Silber bejubelt
hinter dem Quartett aus Italien
die Entscheidung beim letzten Schießen
der Showdown Deutschland gegen Italien
Denise Herrmann Wick auf Bahn 1 daneben
Lisa vitotsi die Italienerin setzt den
ersten Treffer ja eben raus ist
natürlich eine spezielle Situation
natürlich daheim auf Stand eins wo ich
eigentlich bewusst hingegangen bin in
der Hoffnung dass ich ein bisschen
kleinen Windschatten bekommen von stand
zwei weil der Wind ja doch auch mal nach
rechts geht Denise hermannweg verliert
durch die zwei nachlade Patronen Zeit
kann aber Silber absichern
überraschungsgold also für das Quartett
aus Italien die deutsche Mannschaft hat
nach eigenem Bekunden nicht Gold
verloren sondern Silber gewonnen die
Bronze Medaille sichert sich Schweden
und für die deutschen Männer reichte es
zu Platz 5 beim Sieg von Frankreich vor
Norwegen bei den
alpinenweltmeisterschaften feiert Lena
Dürr in marybell den größten Erfolg
ihrer Karriere Bronze im Slalom
zwischen Hoffen und Bangen Lena Dürr
liegt zwar in Führung rette 200
Vorsprung ins Ziel aber es kommen noch
drei rosa fährt eine souveräne Bestzeit
die Kanadierin auf Goldkurs denn wenn
die Holdener aus der Schweiz fädelt ein
und US-Star Michaela shiffrin verliert
das goldduell Jubel im deutschen Team
die Hunderassen auf der Seite und auf
der und heute waren sie auf meiner Seite
und ich habe nicht mehr damit gerechnet
die werden immer so stark unterwegs
Bronze die erste Einzelmedaille für die
31-Jährige aus Garmisch-Partenkirchen
Erfolgserlebnis für die deutschen
Skispringer kurz vor Beginn der
Nordischen Skiweltmeisterschaften vier
unter den besten fünf beim Weltcup in
rasenhoff Rumänien Andreas Wellinger
gewinnt erneut Karl Geiger wird Dritter
in Abwesenheit einiger Topstars und am
21 spieltag der Fußball-Bundesliga muss
Tabellenführer Bayern München einen
Dämpfer hinnehmen der Rekordmeister
verliert in Gladbach mit zwei zu drei in
Unterzahl Oper Mecano sah in der 8
Minute rot in Wolfsburg gewinnt Leipzig
13:0 Freiburg in Bochum 2:0 und Bruno
Labbadia feiert mit Stuttgart seinen
ersten Sieg 13:0 gegen Köln das
Abendspiel Frankfurt Bremen ausführlich
im Sportstudio gestern Augsburg
Hoffenheim 1:0 morgen noch drei Partien
mit den Heimspielen der Bayern verfolge
Union Berlin und Borussia Dortmund so
kann Bayern München an der
Tabellenspitze von Union noch verdrängt
werden und der BVB den Abstand zur
Freiburg und Leipzig wieder vergrößern
Gladbach verbessert sich vorläufig in
die obere Hälfte auf acht am Tabellen
Ende verlässt Stuttgart die
Abstiegsplätze liegt vor Hoffenheim und
Bochum Hertha und Schalke können noch
punkten und mehr wie gewohnt im
Aktuellen Sportstudio 23 Uhr vielen Dank
Christin wir haben zum Schluss noch ein
paar Bilder von der größten Party der
Welt in Rio de Janeiro ist nämlich der
Straßenkarneval zurück nach zwei Jahren
Corona Zwangspause Trommeln sich die
Karnevalsgruppen wieder ausgelassen und
farbenfroh durch Rio und auch im
Sambodrom haben die tollen Tage begonnen
mit dem Wettstreit der Samba Schulen der
aufstiegsklasse ab Sonntag sind dann die
Top-Gruppen der ersten Liga dran
da ist was los nicht brasilianisch aber
ganz akzeptable Wetteraussichten gleich
von Katja horneffer gegen 22 Uhr ordnet
Anne gallinek diesen nachrichtentag im
heute-journal ein morgen an dieser
Stelle Barbara Hellweg ich wünsche Ihnen
noch einen entspanntes Wochenende danke
und auf bald
[Musik]
guten Abend sollten Sie zufällig ab
Rosenmontag einige Stunden draußen
verbringen wollen dann haben sie in dem
Hoch Gabriela einen Verbündeten denn das
bringt häufig Sonnenschein und fast
schon Wärme morgen allerdings muss erst
noch einen namenloses tief über uns
hinwegziehen das folgt ihm die Volker
hinterher und so gibt es erstmal Regen
heute Nacht häufig so zwischen 5 und 15
Liter pro Quadratmeter und zwischen dem
Emsland und der Lausitz können das
durchaus auch 20 Liter pro Quadratmeter
werden es könnte vielleicht auch mal
Grummeln und hier im Nordosten ist eine
einzelne feuchte Schneeflocke auch nicht
ganz ausgeschlossen denn da singen die
Temperaturen in Richtung Gefrierpunkt
sonst bleibt die Nacht bei 10 bis 5 Grad
Männer und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen im kühleren Nordosten
bei fünf bis acht Grad im milderen
Südwesten bei 8 bis 14 Grad und auch
morgen Vormittag regnet es erst noch mal
häufig weiter aber der Regen zieht im
Laufe des Tages weiter Nordosten und
wird auch immer weniger schon von
Tagesbeginn an wird es freundlich sein
hier nordöstlich von Elbe Havel und
Spree da sehen sie häufig die Sonne der
Wind weht noch recht kräftig aus
westlichen Richtungen und an Rosenmontag
und Dienstag ziehen vor allen Dingen
über Norddeutschland und die Küsten
Regenschauer hinweg sonst wird es sehr
sonnig und mild bei Temperaturen von
8-17 Grad schönes Wochenende